[Music]
foreign
let's also come back to the org chart
and Layla could you describe
how that was done what it ended up
looking like
what were the implications and just just
kind of walk us through that and I
remember in our first conversation I
told the story of and maybe not the best
example uh since it is uh ultimately has
been superseded by Netflix and Superior
technology but Blockbuster back in the
day when Blockbuster as a company was
about to become a Blockbuster brought in
I believe someone from McDonald's and
exec to specifically help them with org
chart design I've never designed an org
chart so could you just describe what
happened and where you landed with it
yeah I mean we've gone through a bunch
of different org charts I mean when we
were
from zero to call it 30 employees our
chat was was very flat as in I was
managing everybody
that was that and I actually think you
know maybe I took it a little too far
but I actually think in the first for
the first zero to n where n is around
maybe 20 to 30 people
the best thing you can do as a CEO is be
a micromanager I actually believe that
when you are such a small company
usually you don't quite yet have product
Market fit you haven't really figured
everything out you have one goal get the
product Market fit and I don't think you
should be in the business of you know
kind of like coaching people for this or
that no no just I think you just
micromanage people to like get to
product Market fit I actually believe
that
at some point it really shifts even if
you love micromanaging which I love
micromanaging but I've learned not to do
that anymore even if you love it at some
point this is just becomes you just
can't do it as well and it is in your
best interest to start actually
developing people
and you know that shift should happen
maybe at around 20 I don't know the
exact number
that is when you should really start
having kind of a couple of managers I
think splitting things up into teams
what we did then it's not like we had a
pretty good idea of exactly what our org
chart should look like but what we did
was
we hired our first manager
that wasn't me
it's a woman that this was maybe I don't
know seven years ago something like that
it's a woman that's still with us she's
now the head of all of engineering she
used to be a director of engineering at
Google
and I knew her because after selling
recapture I spent some time at Google I
knew her I really liked her her name is
Natalie glance she's amazing and she you
know she took a much smaller job at
Duolingo she was managing you know kind
of It's a larger job that she had and
she took a smaller job at dueling I
think she really believed in us and she
helped us
well from her eyes where I learned how
to manage people really much better she
actually knew how to manage people
and she really helped us you know kind
of start having a structure of well we
have some managers
and that was
that really made a big difference
starting to have teams then the thing
that we did after that is we discovered
this idea of metrics-based teams which
to this day we use and I think has been
a really really good thing I think this
is not the common thing although some
companies do do it it's not the common
thing so at Duolingo you know the
standard thing that you would have you
know in a company for example at
Duolingo we have the app has a bunch of
different features
one of the features could be like we
have a leaderboard for example I'm a
leaderboard that's a feature
in many companies kind of the normal
thing to do is that you have a
leaderboard team a team that owns that
big feature so just kind of you split it
up by feature these are feature based
teams we do not do feature-based teams
we do metrics-based team so we don't
have a team that owns the leaderboard
instead we have a bunch of teams that
own each a single metric so for example
a metric that we have is time spent
learning what they're what they own is
the number of minutes per day that the
average user uses Duolingo for
and it turns out that changes to the
leaderboard increase or can increase or
decrease time spent learning if you do
that kind of the right or the wrong
thing so that team messes with the
leaderboard a lot but they don't own it
they the only thing they do is they have
this one metric and every quarter it has
to increase and so they just work on
increasing this one metric and they run
hundreds of a b tests to increase this
metric so we discovered that you know
soon after Natalie showed up we
discovered these metric based teams and
we started you know at first our first
metric based team was a retention team
which is look all you have to do is make
sure that users come back every day
and that team
has done all kinds of things really
optimized the streak on Duolingo so this
is this notion of a streak that people
have yeah if people have used it what
every day for seven years I was looking
at the streaks the streak is crazy um we
have well the number is a little larger
but now that we're a public company we
can't reveal numbers as the latest
number we've revealed is that we have
one and a half million daily active
users that have a streak longer than a
year meaning they have not missed a
single day in the last year or longer
so so that that's a that's a very
powerful mechanic the retention team has
worked on that so basically what we did
is we discovered this metric based teams
and what we do now at dueling was when
we care about a metric that we want to
optimize so a metric could be daily
revenue
or you know whatever it is we form a
team around that metric and that has
worked out pretty well that's kind of
one big shift with us
that happened and then the other big
shift that happened is so that that
worked out pretty well at some point we
had like 50 teams or maybe a little less
maybe like 40 teams and that was
starting to become you know we use the
term goat Rodeo it started to become
this craziness and so what we did is we
we decided to pull the teams together
that were similar to each other into
this thing called areas so now for
example we have a monetization area
inside the monetization area we have a
team that owns ad Revenue per day we
have a team that owns subscription
Revenue per day we have a team so so
that and then we have another area
called the growth area where it's just
growing our active uses we have a team
that owns time spent learning we have a
team that owns retention we have another
team that owns new user retention
Etc and so we we split up into areas and
that's how we're split up now
and what has what has been really good
is and the shift for me has been you
know it went from micromanager to kind
of learning how to manage to now
what I do is I you know I'm a manager of
managers well I'm a manager of managers
and managers and managers but at some
point that kind of doesn't matter that
much you're just you're just a manager
of managers is kind of what matters and
I've learned how to start managing
managers much better I've Gotten Good at
it